hier geht's weiter mit einem Antrag der
Unionsfraktion der trägt den Titel
migrationspolitischen Sonderweg in
Europa sofort beendet Beenden der Union
ist es wichtig die Union ist es wichtig
eben Grenzkontrollen an der deutsche
tschechischen Grenze
unverzüglich einzuführen insbesondere
mit dem Blick auf die Balkanroute über
die sich die Anzahl der
Einreisenden nach Europa in jüngster
Zeit wieder deutlich erhöht hat die
Aussprache wird eröffnet und erster
Redner wird sein Andrea Lindholz
stellvertretende Vorsitzende der
Unionsfraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen 2000 Kilometer
von hier hat der Kriegsverbrecher Putin
in Europa die größte flüchtlingskrise
seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg ausgelöst
erst in dieser Woche konnten wir wieder
Raketenangriffe auf die Ukraine erleben
die insbesondere auch die
Zivilbevölkerung Frauen Kinder und
Männer trifft aus der Ukraine sind daher
nach Deutschland in der Zwischenzeit und
eine Million Menschen gekommen und auch
in Polen Tschechien und Moldau haben
viele Schutz gefunden Europa steht
geschlossen an der Seite des
ukrainischen Volkes und darauf können
wir als Europäer stolz sein
seit Wochen steigt allerdings im Zuge
der Krisen die irreguläre asylmigration
stetig an
154.000 Asylanträge wurden dieses Jahr
schon in Deutschland gestellt und unsere
Länder und Kommunen warnen seit Monaten
vor der Überlastung sie verkünden
Aufnahmestopps und sie rufen den Bund um
Hilfe aber die Bundesregierung sie
zögert und zaudert und acht Monate nach
Kriegsbeginn verkündet Frau Feser die
Innenministerin in dieser Woche als
großes Ergebnis ihres Gespräches mit den
Kommunen unter anderem dass der Bund
4000 Wohnplätze zusätzlich bereitstellen
will das reicht nicht aus bei den
aktuellen einreisen sind diese Plätze in
einer Woche belegt aber die Versorgung
der über 1,1 Menschen der erfordert viel
mehr als nur Wohnungen erfordert dass
die Kommunen
personalbereitstellen Kitaplätze
Sprachkurse und vieles mehr und diese
Ressourcen sind und darauf haben die
Städte und Gemeinden hingewiesen endlich
und die Ampel verschleppt an dieser
Stelle seit Monaten seit Januar die
Entscheidung über die Aufteilung der
flüchtlingskosten und selbst zugesagte
Gelder sind in den Ländern bis heute
nicht angekommen
darüber hinaus
aktuell die Mittel für die sprachkitas
sie spart bei den Integrationskursen
über 70 Millionen Euro ein und das ist
insgesamt ein falsches Signal auch an
diejenigen die vor Ort arbeiten und es
zerstört gezielt gute Projekte vor Ort
nicht nachvollziehbar ist warum der
Kanzler bisher so tut als ginge ihnen
das alles gar nichts an wir fordern ihn
endlich und zum wiederholten Male auf
das Thema Migration endlich zur
Chefsache zu machen und wenn er schon im
Kanzleramt keinen flüchtlingskoordinator
eingestellt hat dann sollte es zumindest
zügig einen ressortübergreifenden
flüchtlingsgipfel geben der auch etwas
zu entscheiden hat und Frau Feser die
Innenministerin hat diese Woche
getwittert sie wolle die irreguläre
Migration um die es in unserem Antrag
auch geht begrenzen dafür muss sie aber
auch etwas tun Ankündigungen alleine
reichen nicht und liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen der Ampel stufen Sie doch
endlich die Maghreb-Staaten und Georgien
zu sicheren Herkunftsländern ein das
hatten wir die SPD die FDP und die Union
2019 im Bundestag beschlossen wer das
blockiert das sind die Grünen im
Bundesrat
die Innenministerin
die Innenministerin verlängert zu Recht
die stationären Grenzkontrollen an der
bayerisch-österreichischen Grenze aber
es macht keinen Sinn dass sie Kontrollen
an der deutsch-tschechischen Grenze
ausschließt denn über diesen Weg finden
aktuell die meisten
illegalen einreisen statt und liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Ampel
Grenzkontrollen sind auch ein
Stoppsignal an Schlepper und Schleuser
und der Schlepper und schleuserwesen ist
das was in den letzten Monaten wieder
gravierend zugenommen hat
und liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen von
der Ampel Erdogan hat angedroht er will
eine Million Menschen eine Million
syrische Flüchtlinge 4 Millionen sind
noch in der Türkei abschieben seit
Monaten weisen wir darauf hin dass
endlich durch die Bundesregierung
sichergestellt werden muss dass die
eu-türkei-erklärung gilt handeln Sie
hier endlich hören sie auf falsche
Signale in die Welt zu senden wir wollen
helfen wir helfen aber auch unsere
Mittel in Deutschland sind nicht endlich
was wir brauchen ist eine Politik mit
Herz Verstand und Ordnung und dazu
gehört dass sie endlich handeln vielen
Dank
Andrea Lindholz stellvertretende
Vorsitzende der Unionsfraktion hat den
Antrag ihrer Fraktion zu zur
Migrationspolitik in Deutschland
läutert das ganze in Anwesenheit der
bundesinnenministerin Nancy fäser die ja
am vergangenen Dienstag zu einem
flüchtlingsgipfel ins Innenministerium
eingeladen hat und die Problematik die
aktuelle besprochen und erörtert hat mit
Vertretern aus Ländern Kommunen und
Landkreisen jetzt am Pult Hakan Demir
aus der SPD-Fraktion versprechen
zeichnen sich dadurch aus dass man sie
einhält auch dann wenn sich die Umstände
geändert haben und mit versprechen meine
ich wie ich das auch gestern noch mal
gesagt habe wir haben einen Grundgesetz
wir haben ein Grundgesetz wir haben ein
Asylrecht wir haben internationales
Recht
und dort steht drin dass das Recht auf
Asyl gilt das ist ein Versprechen dass
wir als Land abgegeben haben die
Umstände haben sich erschwert zugegeben
aber dann sagen wir doch nicht das Recht
muss jetzt gekürzt werden sondern wir
sagen dass wir die Umstände ändern
müssen und das macht auch unsere
Innenministerin Nancy fazer
und in ihrem Antrag
fordern Sie
dass es nicht mehr Aufnahmeprogramme
geben soll und wir haben ja auch beide
in der großen Koalition entschieden dass
unsere Soldatinnen und Soldaten und
unsere Organisationen Afghanistan sind
und dort helfen unterstützen wir waren
jetzt 20 Jahre dort Menschen haben uns
unterstützt wir haben gemeinsame Werte
und diese Menschen sind jetzt in Gefahr
und einige von ihnen sind auch schon
leider getötet worden jetzt kann man
sich doch nicht hier hinstellen und
sagen diese Aufnahmeprogramme sind nicht
gut die sollten wir nicht weiterführen
sondern wir haben auch da eine
Verantwortung gegenüber den Menschen die
uns unterstützt haben die letzten 20
Jahre meine Damen und Herren
sie
fordern ihrem Antrag Vorhaben aufzugeben
die angeblich ich zitiere Anreize zu
verstärkter illegaler Einreise auslösen
können um das auch mal einmal zu beenden
das worauf sie ja Hinweisen diese
pulfaktoren wissenschaftlich gesehen
sind sie da in den 60er 70er Jahren noch
verblieben wenn wenn wenn sie Recht
hätten um es mal einmal kurz zu machen
müssen wir sind ja eine Argumentation
wenn sie Recht hätten wären alle
ukrainischen geflüchteten oder mehr
direkt nach Deutschland gekommen aber
die meisten sind in Polen wenn sie Recht
hätten wären alle syrischen geflüchteten
nicht vier Millionen in der Türkei
geblieben sondern während weitergezogen
wenn Sie wenn Sie Recht hätten wenn sie
Recht hätten wären viel mehr Menschen in
dieser Welt in Bewegung wenn diese
pulfaktoren stimmen würden und was ja
eigentlich stimmt ist
es ist so dass die Menschen vor Krieg
und Gewalt fliehen
das ist die Wahrheit und wenn wir schon
mal und wenn wir schon mal dabei sind
weil sie das ja auch gestern noch mal
gesagt haben sie sprechen immer von
schutzquoten
sie sagen dann 40 Prozent schutzquote
sie verschweigen aber dass es eine
bereinigte gesamtschutzquote gibt Herr
sei es gibt eine bereinigte
gesamtschutzquote da rechnen sie nämlich
alle Zahlen noch mal raus die sich
formal klären lassen also ein Drittel
davon
entscheidet das BAMF gar nicht wenn Sie
diese Zahl rausrechnen dann haben sie
eine bereinigte schutzquote von den
Menschen von etwa 70 Prozent wenn man
sich das letzte Jahr anguckt so jetzt
können wir uns natürlich darüber
streiten und sagen ja 30 Prozent ist
doch zu viel aber es ist eine Unwahrheit
einfach zu sagen dass 60 Prozent der
Menschen kein Recht haben hier zu sein
und kommen wir zum zu ihrer regulären
Migration sie haben es jetzt gerade noch
mal reingerufen ein Mensch der nach
Deutschland kommt und dann sagt er
möchte Asyl beantragen und da komme ich
auch wieder zu dem Punkt Rechtsstaat was
ihnen ja wichtig ist und uns auch dann
prüft man diesen Asylantrag
das macht man einfach das ist
internationales Recht das ist unser
Recht und das tun wir auch und das auch
gut so
ein Beispiel was was ihre Länder
unionsgeführten Länder jetzt gerade
vielleicht nicht so gut machen ein
Beispiel der Fall des 41-jährigen reser
er der im Oktober eine Ausbildung im
Pflegebereich beginnen sollte er wurde
in Passau unter einem falschen Vorwand
festgenommen und sollte in den Iran
abgeschoben werden in ein Land das
gerade mit extremer Gewalt gegen
Menschen vorgeht die für Freiheit und
die Rechte von Frauen einstehen nur
durch großen öffentlichen Druck wurde
diese Abschiebung ausgesetzt für sie ist
vielleicht ein geduldeter der in Passau
eine Ausbildung beginnen möchte ein
pull-faktor für uns ist diese Person
eine Zukunft und ein Mehrwert für
unseren Arbeitsmarkt dankeschön
Deutschland hat ein Versprechen
abgegeben in Form unseres Grundgesetzes
in Formen von internationalen Verträgen
in Form unseres Asylrechts wenn wir
davon abrücken verliert unser ganzes
Land an Glaubwürdigkeit wer sollte uns
dann noch glauben auch deshalb ist es
klar für uns wir werden nicht abrücken
vom Recht wir werden nicht aufgeben wir
werden dort weitermachen dankeschön
[Applaus]
nächster Redner für die afd-fraktion DR
Bernd Baumann
[Applaus]
geht es hier nicht
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
die CDU legt heute einen Antrag vor sie
fordert die Regierung dringend auf die
neue migrantenwelle zu stoppen es käme
zu viele Asylanten über Balkanroute und
Mittelmeer also aus orienton Afrika die
CDU verlangt zur Abwehr dieser Migranten
allen Ernstes nationale Grenzkontrollen
die CDU nationale Grenzkontrollen sie
waren doch jetzt 16 Jahre an der Macht
und haben effektive Grenzkontrollen wie
der Teufel das Weihwasser verabscheut
und alle unsere Anträge zurückgewiesen
dieser Sache
dadurch haben sie Millionen Menschen aus
Orient und Afrika ermöglicht
unkontrolliert nach Deutschland zu
kommen ihre weltfremde Willkommenskultur
hat unsere Städte unsere Dörfer unsere
ganze Heimat in Kern verändert
und heute heute stellen sich hier hin
und tun so als hätten sie mit all dem
gar nichts zu tun als seien sie eine
konservative Partei eine die unsere
Heimat vor illegalen Migranten schützen
will meine Damen und Herren auf der nach
oben offenen heuchlerskala ist das ein
neuer schmutziger Rekord
als zweites stellen sich heute hier hin
und verlangt dringend Abschiebungen ich
zitiere aus dem Antrag man traut seinen
Augen kaum die CDU fordert endlich die
angekündigte rückführungsoffensive in
die Tat umzusetzen was für eine
Dreistigkeit muss man schon sagen 16
Jahre haben sie als Regierung genau das
Gegenteil gemacht sie haben 16 Jahre an
den Hebeln der Macht verhindert dass es
so nennenswerten Abschiebung gab das
waren sie und niemand anders
schlimmer noch vor jeder Wahl hatte ihre
CDU-Kanzlerin ausdrücklich versprochen
dass die Hunderttausenden abgelehnten
Asylbewerber abgeschoben werden wenn man
nur die CDU wählt vor der Bundestagswahl
2017 Merkel wörtlich das wichtigste ist
Rückführung Rückführung und nochmals
Rückführung anderes Mal versprach sie
ich zitiere eine nationale
Kraftanstrengung für Rückführung und
danach genau das Gegenteil sie haben
immer weniger abgeschoben wenn jemand
jemals in der abendländischen Geschichte
seit der attischen Demokratie vor 2.400
Jahren eine Partei mit äußerster
Niedertracht zu Werke gegangen ist dann
ist das diese CDU in Sachen Abschiebung
Grenzkontrolle ohne vernünftige
migrationsmanagement und Millionen
Einwanderern
aus dem heutigen CDU-Antrag zu
verschärfen und der Migrationspolitik
lernt man eine ganze Menge über die CDU
und wie sie derzeit innerlich
aufgestellt ist rhetorisch blinkt sie in
reichen Worthülsen oft rechts und
konservativ macht dann aber in
Wirklichkeit das Gegenteil das sieht man
auch auf ganz anderen Themenfeldern zum
Beispiel auf ihrem letzten Parteitag
darüber nahm die CDU glatt den Kern des
Links grünen Weltbildes eine Frauen
zwangsquote anstatt Gleichberechtigung
wie vernünftige freiheitliche und
konservative Politiker das fordern will
die CDU jetzt Gleichstellung also
zwangsquoten für Frauen in der gesamten
Partei das machen ansonsten nur Linke
und Grüne was kommt denn als nächstes
Herr Merz
migrantenquoten in der CDU
lgbt-quoten und die Regenbogenflagge in
jedem Dienstzimmer womit müssen wir
rechnen
sie hatten doch eine programmatische
Erneuerung angekündigt unter dem
angeblich konservativen Parteichef märz
das ganze ist doch eine Farce die
Quittung dafür haben sie gerade bei den
Landtagswahlen in Niedersachsen kassiert
das schlechteste Ergebnis aller Zeiten
kein Wunder der Wähler ist doch nicht
doof da merkt das doch
wie man Migrationspolitik mitten in
Europa als Staat in Europa besser machen
kann zeigen Länder wie Dänemark dort hat
sogar eine Sozialdemokratie kapiert eine
sozial demokratische Regierung wie es
geht Asylverfahren müssen dort künftig
vom Ausland aus betrieben werden der
dänische Staat schließt dazu Abkommen
mit Nachbarstaaten der Herkunftsländer
die Schutzbedürftigkeit wird in
rechtlich einwandfreien Verfahren
geprüft zeigen sich echte Asylgründe
werden die Leute geschützt und versorgt
im heimatlichen Kulturkreis und sind
dort gesichert für das dänische
Staatsgebiet selbst gilt offiziell das
Ziel Null Asyl die Regierung schafft so
echten Schutz für echte Flüchtlinge also
für Menschen die keine 10.000 Dollar an
Schleuser zahlen können die sie nach
Europa bringen und der dänische
Sozialstaat bleibt den Armen den
Rentnern und bedürftigen Familien in
Dänemark Vorbehalt meine Damen und
Herren das ist eine für alle Seiten gute
Lösung das sollten wir uns in
Deutschland zum Vorbild nehmen
[Applaus]
Ideen stehen für eine andere für eine
neue Politik sie haben begriffen dass es
eben auch kulturelle Gründe sind wenn
Integration in Europa kolossal scheitert
vor allem dann wenn größere
Einwandererzahlen aus kulturell ganz
andersartigen Regionen kommen mit ganz
fremden Frauenbildern Menschenbildern
und Vorstellungen von gemeinsamen
Zusammenleben selbst ein sozial Demokrat
wieder dänische Integrationsminister
bekennt das jetzt ganz offen er sieht
überall in Europa eskaliert ist und
immer sind es die gleichen
Herkunftsgruppen die beteiligt sind wenn
es im Nachbarland Schweden an allen
Ecken brennt weil migrantische Banden
ganze Städte terrorisieren wenn in
Frankreich sogenannte boniös brennen wo
ganze Generation von Politikern aus dem
linken und rechten Lager alles versucht
haben mit allen Mitteln und es nicht
geschafft haben ähnlich geht es in
Belgien ähnlich in Niederland ähnliche
Großbritannien und bald auch eigentlich
schon bei uns
eine Politik die solch schmerzliche
Erkenntnisse endlich aufnimmt und ohne
Scheuklappen nach neuen innovativen
Lösungen sucht eine solche Politik ist
modern eine solche Politik ist modern
die neue Politik in Dänemark und
demnächst auch in Italien ist deshalb
hochmodern die Migrationspolitik von CDU
und SPD und FDP und grün ist es nicht
sie atmet den alten linken ideologischen
Mief der 68er damit sind die heutigen
Probleme nicht zu lösen ihre Zeit ist
vorbei
das zeigen auch die jüngsten Wahlsiege
unserer Freunde überall in Europa von
Italien im Süden bis Schweden ganz hoch
in den Norden Europas das ist die
Zukunft so sieht moderne Politik aus und
dafür steht in Deutschland nur die AFD
meine Damen und Herren
[Applaus]
nächster Redner für die Fraktion Bündnis
90 die Grünen Julian Pahlke
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Demokraten was heute von der
Union wieder zur Debatte gestellt wird
ist der grundsätzliche und
unveräußerliche Schutz von Menschen auf
der Flucht ich will meine vier Minuten
mal dafür nutzen um mit ein paar ihrer
Alternativen Fakten aufzuräumen zuerst
das Ausspielen von Menschen auf der
Flucht wenn Menschen fliehen dann tun
sie das aus Not aus Verzweiflung niemand
aber verlässt freiwillig seine Heimat
und begibt sich auf eine
lebensgefährliche Flucht diese Menschen
haben erst einmal das Recht ein
Asylantrag zu stellen ob in Deutschland
oder anderswo in Europa und das ist
keine Utopie das ist das wird sie
überraschende europäisches Recht sie
aber spielen geflüchtete gegeneinander
aus die unterteilen in gute und
schlechte geflüchtete gerade so wie es
ihnen passt das Recht auf einen
Asylantrag kennt kein gut und kein
schlecht das Recht auf Asyl kennt nur
das Individuen egal ob jemand vor den
Bomben in der Ukraine oder den Bomben in
Syrien flieht dieses Grundrecht ist ein
zentrales Vermächtnis aus der Nazizeit
und der Begriff so klitorismus ist zu
Recht Unwort des Jahres 2013 geworden
und wurde zuletzt von russischen
Propaganda Medien kommuniziert und eben
von Ihnen Herr nervt dem größten dem
Parteivorsitzenden der größten
Oppositionsfraktion wer bei uns Schutz
sucht ist kein sozial Tourist sondern
ein Mensch mit Ängsten auf der Suche
nach Sicherheit und das ist oft die Rede
von der sogenannten
illegalen Einwanderung wenn aber kaum
legale Wege zur Flucht und Migration
bereitgestellt werden dann sind Menschen
gezwungen auf anderen Wegen Sicherheit
zu suchen die häufigsten Asylanträge von
denjenigen die nach ihrer Definition
illegal eingereist sind stammen übrigens
aus Syrien Afghanistan und dem Irak sie
würden diesen Menschen am liebsten die
Tür vor der Nase zuschlagen und ihnen
genau dieses Recht nehmen sie
suggerieren mit der Konstruktion einer
illegalen Einreise das ja legale Wege
bestehen würden dass diese Menschen also
anderswo Schutz suchen könnten diese
Wege gibt es quasi nicht und das ist ein
Problem das über die Bundesrepublik
hinausgeht denn Flucht ist längst eine
globale Realität Kriege und Konflikte
sind eine globale Realität diese
Realität werden auch sie nicht ändern
können stattdessen braucht es sichere
und legale Wege zur Einreise damit auch
Menschen die vor dem Bomben in Syrien
fliehen einen sicheren Ort finden und
sie leben das europäische Festland
erreichen denn auch für sie gilt das
europäische Asylrecht und zum dritten es
ist gerade ständig die Rede vom
sogenannten pulfaktor also mal im Ernst
der pull-faktor ist ein Konzept der
Migrationsforschung aus den 60ern das
ist ungefähr derzeitpunkt wo sie als
Union inhaltlich stehen geblieben sind
der pull-faktor ist eines ihrer
Konstrukte mit dem Sie lediglich
versuchen die Flucht eines Menschen als
illegitim dastehen zu lassen weil sie
diesen Menschen allein wegen seiner
Herkunft ablehnen diese Theorie vom
polfaktor ist falsch und sie ist Teil
der Hetze gegen Schutzsuchende den
pull-faktor gibt es nicht
kein Mensch verlässt seine Familie seine
Heimat oder den Ort dessen Sprache man
spricht und wo man sich auskennt wegen
ein bisschen Sozialhilfe die meisten
Ukrainerinnen sind deshalb auch nicht in
Deutschland sondern in Polen nicht weil
man da eine so finanzielle
üppige finanzielle Unterstützung bekommt
sondern weil es dort eine große Diaspora
gibt weil das Land direkt da nach bei
der Ukraine ist mit diesem gefährlichen
Gerede gewinnen sie keine Stimmen mit
diesem gefährlichen Gerede verliert man
in Niedersachsen Wahlen das haben wir am
letzten Sonntag Gott sei Dank gesehen
und wenn wir wenn wir über Ausspielen
von Menschen auf der Flucht reden von
vermeintlich illegaler Migration oder
vom vermeintlichen pulleffekt bei all
dem Herr frei bei all dem geht es am
Ende des Tages zum Menschen um Menschen
die vor einigen Monaten noch in den
Keller von gesessen haben die von der
Taliban verfolgt werden oder Menschen
die ihr Leben auf der Flucht riskieren
das sind keine Dinge und das sind keine
Waffen und das sind keine Gefahrengüter
frei das Menschen dankeschön
Julian Pahlke war das Fraktion Bündnis
90 die Grünen in dieser Aussprache über
einen Antrag der cdu/csu-fraktion der
den Titel trägt
migrationspolitischen Sonderweg in
Europa beenden gerichtet das Ganze an
die Bundesregierung und hier kommt die
nächste Rednerin in dieser Debatte gökei
Akbulut aus der Linksfraktion
und Kollegen
gegenüber gefürchteten aus der Ukraine
war erfreulich aber leider nur von
kurzer Dauer mit ihrem Antrag den wir
heute hier diskutieren zeigt die Union
dass sie wieder zurückgekehrt ist zu
ihrer das Boot ist voll Rhetorik wir
benötigen gerade dieser Tage dringend
Solidarität gegenüber Menschen die vor
Krieg fliehen mussten und keine
profilierungs-
ihre Aussage Herr mehr als zum
angeblichen sozialtourismus der
ukrainischen Kriegsflüchtlinge war quasi
das staatssignal es geht wieder los mit
dem Fischen am rechten Rand bei der
Union ohne jede Prüfung der Faktenlage
verbreiten sie Herr Merz diese
Behauptungen aus pro russischen Kanälen
das ist schäbig und ein Schlag ins
Gesicht der Menschen die vor dem Krieg
in der Ukraine fliehen mussten
nach einer halbherzigen Entschuldigung
haben Sie Herr märz ein paar Tage später
nachgelegt die aktuelle Regierung so
behaupten sie würde Tür und Tor öffnen
für eine ungeeignete
Einwanderungspolitik in die gleiche
Richtung geht auch dieser Antrag heute
erst er stellte so da als ob in
Deutschland Anreize für illegale
Migration geschaffen werden diese
Behauptung des deutschen Sozialsystems
die Behauptung dass deutsche
Sozialsystem sei ein prüfaktor ist
nachweislich falsch sie ist gerade zu
grotesk angesichts der zahlreichen
schrecklichen Kriege die Menschen zur
Flucht zwingen
niemand Herr Merz verlässt freiwillig
seine Heimat um hier in einer
Massenunterkunft zu wohnen und
Leistungen zu beziehen die unter dem
Hartz IV Niveau liegen und wie ein
Mensch zweiter Klasse hier in
Deutschland behandelt zu werden
aber schauen wir doch mal auf die
Faktenlage ja die Aufnahme und die
Betreuung der geflüchteten ist eine
große Herausforderung für die Kommunen
deshalb muss die Bundesregierung Städte
und Gemeinden in viel größeren Umfang
unterstützen als jetzt
tatsache ist auch dass eine Million
Flüchtlinge aus der Ukraine Schutz in
Deutschland erhalten haben daneben
wurden dieses Jahr bislang rund 150.000
Asylanträge gestellt und 20 Prozent
dieser Anträge stammen von hier
geborenen Kindern die nicht zugewandert
sind die asylzuwanderung über welche
Route auch immer ist also nicht der
Grund weshalb die
unterbringungskapazitäten in einigen
Regionen erschöpft sind das Problem
liegt in der verteilen Wohnungspolitik
die ja komplett dem Markt unterworfen
ist und es kann nicht sein dass Menschen
hier gegeneinander ausgespielt werden
auf einen weiteren Punkt ihres Antrages
möchte ich noch eingehen sie sprechen
von den ukrainischen geflüchteten auf
auf der einen Seite denen ihre volle
Solidarität und auf der anderen Seite
vom Personen die einen Asylantrag
stellen diese Gegenüberstellung von
guten und schlechten Flüchtlingen können
und werden wir nicht akzeptieren wir
lehnen die zwei Klassen
Flüchtlingspolitik ab wir als LINKE
unterscheiden nicht ob jemand vor dem
Bomben Putins fliehen muss oder vor den
chemischen Waffen eines Erdogans wer
fliehen muss egal woher für den Schutz
und Aufnahme unsere Solidarität ist hier
unteilbar wir setzen uns ein für
entrechtlichte Menschen an den
europäischen Grenzen
die Union macht mit falschen
Behauptungen erneut Stimmung gegen
geflüchtete um Wählerinnen und Wähler
wieder am rechten Rand abzugreifen dass
wir die aber kaum gelingen wer Rassisten
nach dem Mund redet macht sie nur noch
stärker
was wir heute und in diesem schwierigen
Zeiten brauchen sind demokratische
Parteien die eine klare Kante gegen
rechts zeigen und keine Union die in
braunen Gewässern fischt vielen Dank
die migrationspolitische Sprecherin der
Linksfraktion es geht hier weiter um den
Antrag der Union mit dem Titel den
migrationspolitischen Sonderweg in
Europa zu beenden und jetzt Stefan
thomey Ausschuss für Inneres und Heimat
und einer der Parlamentarischen
Geschäftsführer der FDP-Fraktion
Damen und Herren liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen die Union legt uns heute einen
Antrag vor mit dem Titel
migrationspolitischen Sonderweg in
Europa beenden und ich überlege mir so
was will uns die Union damit eigentlich
sagen denn miationspolitischen Sonderweg
Deutschlands hat der Wähler vor einem
Jahr beendet also die Union in die
Opposition gesandt hat und seither wird
niemand mehr davon sprechen können dass
es eine Herrschaft des Unrechts
odergleichen in Deutschland gebe ich
will an ein paar Beispielen widerlegen
dass wir einen ein Sonderweg gehen und
viel mehr zeigen dass wir Dinge planen
die die sinnvoll und richtig und
nützlich sind wir wollen nämlich
insbesondere statt irregulärer
illegaler Migration Wege zu regulärer
und legale Migration eröffnen weil wir
doch auch auf dem Arbeitsmarkt Menschen
brauchen die etwas beitragen zum
Gelingen unserer Gesellschaft und
deswegen brauchen wir Möglichkeiten wie
Menschen legal ins Land kommen können
dazu schaffen wir die chancenkarte dazu
verbessern wir die die BlueCard damit
nicht nur Menschen mit hoher
Qualifikation mit akademischer
Ausbildung nach Deutschland kommen
können sondern auch ganz einfache
Arbeitskräfte die bei uns arbeiten
können die Sie bei uns ausbilden lassen
können daran fehlt doch bei uns und das
ist
zugleich ein Punkt der das reduziert was
sie pull-effekt oder falsch Anreiz
nennen denn wer wird denn noch viel Geld
bezahlen an Schlepper und Schleuser wird
sein Leben Leib Gesundheit Freiheit auf
Spiel setzen in der Wüste auf dem Meer
wenn es ein ganz einfach legalen Weg
gibt in Deutschland zu arbeiten und hier
eine Ausbildung zu absolvieren
ein zweiter Punkt dieses Thema Chancen
Aufenthalt von dem sie auch immer sagen
das löst pull-effekte aus und schafft
falsche Anreize worum geht es denn
eigentlich
2015 und 16 kam einfach ganz ganz viele
Menschen nach Deutschland von den ganz
ganz viele immer noch noch hier sind die
seit Jahren seit sechs oder sieben
Jahren bei uns geduldet sind keine echte
Perspektive entwickeln können die Kinder
sprechen zum Teil besser Deutsch also
Sprache ihrer Eltern und Großeltern und
jetzt sagen Sie ja gut aber wenn wir das
diesen Chancen Aufenthalt schaffen
legalisieren durch ein illegalen Status
pull-effekte falsche Anreize
sozialtourismus aber worum geht es denn
eigentlich wenn man herausfiltern ob
nicht da Potenziale für uns alle drin
stecken pragmatische Lösungen um diesen
Zustand zu beenden wenn wir schon genau
wissen diese Zustand wird sich nicht so
schnell beenden lassen überlegen doch
wie können das konstruktiv und Münzen
und darum geht es uns und zwar ein sach
abschließende in der Vergangenheit sich
zugetragen hat deswegen auch stichtinger
tagsbezogen das löst keine falschen
Anreize für die Zukunft mehr auch sein
wollen Dinge die in Vergangenheit falsch
gelaufen sind in ihrer Regierungszeit
wollen wir es endlich einmal lösen und
das ist das Dach doch worum es uns geht
für die Zukunft
planen wir etwas anderes
[Applaus]
siehe chancenkarte für bessere Flughafen
wir wollen Dinge Vergangenheit
abarbeiten aufräumen was noch ungelöst
herumliegt ein dritter Punkt wo ich auch
mir denke wo ist da der Sonderweg das
ist Verfahrensbeschleunigung wir wollen
schneller Klarheit schaffen und auch das
ist auch in der Vergangenheit nie oder
jedenfalls nie gut gelungen da ist auch
von ihrerseit von
anti-abschiedeindustrie gesprochen
worden wo einfach der Rechtsweg
ausgeschöpft worden ist was uns gelingen
muss das ist den Rechtsweg beschleunigen
ohne Rechte zu beschneiden und das ist
kein leichte Aufgabe das wissen sie doch
auch und was sie in eineinhalb
Wahlperioden nicht geschafft haben da
gibt es noch mal eineinhalb Jahre Zeit
um diese schwierige Aufgabe auch zu
lösen meine Damen und Herren das ist
doch kein sonderwechsel in der
Beschreibung und das vierte Beispiel ist
sie ansprechen will dieses Thema
Rückführungen und Abschiebungen da haben
wir zurzeit ein ganz ganz aktuelles
schwieriges Beispiel wie wir dann
umgehen wollen wenn ich das Beispiel
Iran wo wir
problematische Bilder täglich bekommen
wo wir eine unsichere labile Lage haben
und viele Länder abschiebestopps
verhängt haben und die Innenministerin
zu Recht wie ich finde gesagt habe hat
das aber Straftäter und Gefährder von
diesen abschiebestopps nicht umfasst
sein sollten das ist immer kritischer
Punkt ich halte es für legitim denn ob
jemand Straftäter ist oder Gefährder es
hat mir irgendwie selber in der Hand man
kann einfach bleiben lassen und deswegen
finde ich wenn jemand Straftaten begeht
und Anschläge plant dann kalkuliert er
irgendwie auch mit ein dass wir bei
unserem nein konsequent sind und an
jemanden abschieben das ist auch die
Konsequenz dessen und da frage ich Sie
wo ist denn da der Sonderweg den sie
beklagen nein als Fazit wir begehen
keinen Sonderweg sondern wir versuchen
Dinge die in der Vergangenheit nicht gut
gelaufen sind besser zu machen eine
Paradigmenwechsel hinzubringen und das
ist kein Sonderweg und es ist viele
nützlich und gute Dinge die wir planen
sagt Stefan thomey aus der FDP-Fraktion
zum Antrag der Unionsfraktion die ja der
Ansicht ist die Bundesregierung Folge
einem migrationspolitischen Sonderweg
nein sagt Stefan Thomi wir gehen neue
Wege denn wir wollen ja statt illegaler
illegale Migration die wir auch brauchen
für den Arbeitsmarkt für die
Unionsfraktion jetzt Alexander throm der
innenpolitische Sprecher Präsidentin und
Kollegen also wir haben das ist absehbar
in diesem Jahr das Jahr mit der höchsten
Flucht Zuwanderung in der Geschichte der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland und das was
ich hier von der Ampel höre das ist
völlig unangemessen wie Sie mit dieser
großen Herausforderung umgehen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
geschuldet ist das natürlich vor allem
den unzähligen Angriffskrieg von
Russland gegenüber der Ukraine und die
ukrainischen Flüchtlinge haben unsere
volle Solidarität daran gibt es keinen
Zweifel aber es kommen auch bis heute
150.000 Menschen irregulär über die
Grenze insbesondere aus Südosteuropa das
werden die 200.000 in diesem Jahr sein
wir haben davor gewarnt die Ampel hat
die Lage unterschätzt noch in diesem
Frühjahr hat die Innenministerin sich
für zusätzliche Aufnahmeprogramme auf
europäischer Ebene bei der Koalition der
Willigen feiern lassen jetzt twittert
sie ich habe es gestern im
Innenausschuss schon verraten ich habe
erstmals ein Tweet der Innenministerin
Geleit sie hat nämlich getwittert dass
sie illegale Einreisen stoppen will
wunderbar das ist deshalb
Verständlichkeit es hat ein kleiner
Shitstorm ausgelöst das haben wir heute
auch bei den Grünen bei der SPD und bei
den Jusos gemerkt die dieses so genau
nicht wollen und es zeigt doch dass sie
ein Problem haben das zeigt was sie mit
der Ampelkoalition tatsächlich wollen
Herr Kollege Thome das zeigt auch den
deutschen Sonderweg den sie mit der
Ampelkoalition in der Migrationspolitik
in Europa fahren wir wollen diesen
Paradigmenwechsel sie wollen Anreize
schaffen sie wollen weitere Öffnungen
sie wollen weitere Zuwanderung und das
sind in der Tat bulleffekte das ist
nicht nur das chancenaufenthaltsrecht
und es sind nicht
kettendungen das sagen sie die
Unwahrheit da führen Sie die Leute in
die Irre auch ein gestatterter der noch
im Asylverfahren ist kann wenn er fünf
Jahre da ist ihr Chancen
Aufenthaltsrecht in Anspruch nehmen und
sie schaffen dieses nur weil sie damit
Personen mit ungeklärter Identität die
Brücke in ein Daueraufenthaltsrecht
schaffen alle anderen gedulden brauchen
diese Brücke nicht da gibt es schon
andere Lösungen und was noch viel
schlimmer ist bei ihnen sind Jugendliche
zukünftig bis 27 Jahre jedenfalls wenn
sie Ausländer sind die wollen allen die
bis 27 Jahre hier sind und länger als
drei Jahre hier sind zukünftig ein
Daueraufenthaltsrecht erschaffen und
wenn das kein Anreiz in der Welt ist
dann weiß ich es auch nicht nein sie
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Ampel
der Kollegen sie sind
glauben Sie eine Zwischenfrage aus der
SPD-Fraktion von Herrn Demir ja ihr seid
gerne das gibt mir die Gelegenheit auch
noch auf das zu antworten was sie gerade
vorhin gesagt haben darum geht es ja
auch jetzt darum danke schön dass Sie
das einmal freigeben zwei Sachen zu zu
dem einen Punkt Solidarität mit den
ukrainischen geflüchteten das finde ich
sehr gut und das ist auch
selbstverständlich frage mich aber auch
nur warum nicht auch Solidarität mit
anderen geflüchteten aus anderen Ländern
die wenn Sie hier hinkommen
wahrscheinlich auch eine Anerkennung
bekommen also ich frag sie das auch ganz
offen zweite Frage wieder zum Chancen
Aufenthaltsrecht wir hatten die
Diskussion mit Herrn Seif gestern auch
sie haben jetzt gerade behauptet dass
die Menschen die jetzt das Bleiberecht
bekommen irgendwie die Identität nicht
geklärt haben und so weiter das Chancen
Aufenthaltsrecht ist ja dafür da dieses
eine Jahr dass die Personen die
Identität innerhalb dieser Zeit klären
wenn das gemacht worden ist dann kriegen
sie eine Chance warum möchten für diesen
Menschen keine Chance geben und vor
allem vielleicht auch im Kontext des
fachkräfteeinwanderungsgesetzes da sind
wir uns ja einig sie möchten ja auch
Menschen hier in diesem Land haben die
dann den Fachkräftemangel dann
minimieren warum nicht mit diesen
Menschen zusätzlich Dankeschön also das
sind drei Fragen frau Präsidentin da
brauche ich entsprechend Zeit darauf
antworten zu können zunächst mal zu der
Frage mit der Solidarität sie haben
gerade vorhin auch das Recht auf Asyl
abgehoben in ihrer Rede das stellt auch
überhaupt niemand in Frage aber Geld des
europäisches Recht ist es eben auch dass
es keinen Anspruch darauf gibt sich
auszusuchen in welches Land man geht man
hat kein Recht auf freie Durchreise und
die Menschen wenn sie nach Deutschland
kommen kommen aus dick sicheren
Drittstaaten und deswegen fordern wir
dass wir genau dieses Recht zukünftig
durchsetzen zweiter Punkt
chancenaufenthaltsrecht
[Applaus]
alle geduldeten
mit Ausnahme derer mit ungeklärter
Identität haben nach aktuellem geltendem
Recht die Möglichkeit nach sechs bzw
acht Jahren ein Daueraufenthaltsrecht zu
erreichen wenn Sie die dortigen
Voraussetzungen erfüllen es gibt eine
einzige Gruppe von geduldeten die diese
Möglichkeit nicht haben und das sind
diejenigen die eine ungeklärte Identität
haben weil unser Staat bisher immer
unisono über alle demokratischen
Fraktionen hinweg gesagt hat wir wollen
wissen wer bei uns in Deutschland lebt
dies ist auch eine Frage der inneren
Sicherheit und ihr
chancenaufenthaltsrecht
ist nur notwendig und dieser
Personengruppe abzuhelfen und die
Möglichkeit zu geben in diesem Jahr ihre
Identität zu offenbaren das machen sie
bisher nämlich deshalb nicht weil sie
dann abgeschoben werden würden das war
die Wahrheit ist ihr
chancenaufenthaltsrecht ist in der Tat
ihre rückführungsoffensive sie
bereinigen damit die abschiebestatistik
aber sie schaffen keine keine gerechte
Lösungen für diejenigen die hier
eigentlich unser Land verlassen müssen
liebe Kollegen und Kollegen
und jetzt diese Frage zu dem Thema der
Fachkräfte zu dem Thema der Fachkräfte
also diejenigen aber Chancen
Aufenthaltsrecht nutzen sollen sind
keine Fachkräfte die müssen auch ihren
Lebensunterhalt nicht vollständig
erfüllen sondern nur überwiegend und
deswegen ist es auch nicht richtig un-
und minder qualifizierte eine legalen
Weg nach Deutschland zu geben auch wenn
die FDP beispielsweise die balkanregel
ausweiten will auch Maghreb auf Indien
auf Nigeria und Gambia dies liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Ampel ist
in der Tat der falsche Weg
in der Tat
diese Bundesregierung ist auf
europäischer Ebene der
migrationspolitische
Geisterfahrer alle europäischen Länder
alle europäischen Länder begrenzen mit
nationalen Maßnahmen
illegale Migration soweit dies möglich
ist
einzig Deutschland unter der
ampelregierung geht genau den
entgegengesetzten Weg und öffnet und
liberalisiert und schafft zusätzliche
Anreize nach Deutschland zu kommen mit
fluchtmigration dies ist falsch und das
schadet am Ende auch unserer
Gesellschaft und das schadet auch der
Anerkennung für die Menschen die
tatsächlich hier notwendig sind deswegen
kein Land in Europa folgt ihnen alle
sind dankbar dass Deutschland diese
Lasten die sie offensichtlich bereit
sind einzugehen für die europäischen
Länder übernimmt unsere Forderung ist
hören Sie mit diesem Irrweg auf und
kehren Sie liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
sagt Alexander throm aus der
Unionsfraktion wo er innenpolitischer
Sprecher ist und ihm folgt jetzt Gülle
Stern Yüksel aus der SPD-Fraktion sie
ist Mitglied im Ausschuss für Inneres
und Heimat
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren liebe zuhören
und Zuhörern auf den Tribünen gestern
Abend sprach ich vor diesem Rednerpult
zu einem populistischen Antrag der AFD
heute debattieren wir erneut zu
Migrationspolitik man merkt den
Unterschied kaum aber diesmal zu einem
Antrag der CDU CSU
sehr geehrter Herr Merz eines vorweg
zuletzt haben sie versucht auf sich auf
den Rücken der Schwächsten zu
profilieren anders ist nicht zu erklären
dass sie geflüchtete aus der Ukraine
kurz vor der niedersachsenwahl des
sozialtourismus besichtigen
so verhalten sich nur Populisten und
Hetzer die die Gesellschaft Spalten
wollen
liebe Kollegen Kollegen der Union wenn
meine Wortwahl als verletzend empfunden
wird dann bitte ich dafür um aller in
aller Form Moment entschuldigung aber
genau mit diesen Worten hat der
CDU-Vorsitzende versucht sich wieder vom
Unwort des Sozialgerichts zu
distanzieren merken Sie selbst oder das
war keine echte entschuldigung das war
ein zurückruder nach einem kalkulierten
tabu-buch ganz im rechtspopulistischer
Manier
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen wohin ein
solcher Tabu wo führt sehen wir am
vorliegenden Antrag der Union während
gerade wieder russische Raketen in
ukrainischen Wohngebieten einschlagen
Raunen märz und seine Fraktion von
migrationsplänen die Anreize zu
verstärkter illegale Einreise auslösen
können statt konkret zu werden welche
angeblichen Anreize Ländern gemeint sind
wird unterstellt dass die
Bundesregierung illegale Migration
befördere das Gegenteil ist richtig wer
illegale Migration eindämmen will muss
legale einwanderungsmöglichkeiten
schaffen
im Koalitionsvertrag haben wir genau das
geregelt
auch die zweite Forderung im Antrag ist
unredlich ausgerechnet die Union macht
sich zum Anwalt der Kommunen fordert
umfassende Hilfe im Rahmen der
verfügbaren Haushaltsmittel natürlich
ohne jeglichen Finanzierungsvorschlag
ist Ihnen denn entgangen dass der Bund
zwei Milliarden Euro an Unterstützung
bereitgestellt hat
drittens fordern sie eine fortlaufende
Kommunikation mit Ländern und Kommunen
darf ich mal fragen wo sie am Dienstag
waren da traf sich bundesinnenministerin
Feser mit den kommunalen
Spitzenverbänden und Vertretern der
Länder zu aktuellen
flüchtlingssituationen Länder und
Kommunen werden monatlich über alle
vorliegenden Erkenntnisse informiert und
eng einbezogen dazu injiziert sie auch
eine gemeinsame digitale Plattform wo
sich Fachleute unter anderem über
Verbesserung bei der Unterbringung von
geflüchteten austauschen können und die
Ministerin hat auch angekündigt dass wir
weitere bundesimmobilien für geflüchtete
öffnen
viertens dringen sie auf europäische
Lösungen auch das geschieht bereits
während ihr Innenminister Seehofer von
Europa immer nur sprach um eigene
untätigkeiten zu verschleiern geht
unsere Ministerin voran so wart sie
schon Anfang des Jahres für eine
Koalition der aufnahmebereiten
Mitgliedstaaten um die Weiterentwicklung
des europäischen Asylsystems endlich in
Gang zu bringen
außerdem haben wir schnell und erstmalig
gemeinsam mit unseren EU-Partnern die
Richtlinie über den temporären Schutz
aktiviert
so haben wir Schutzsuchenden europaweit
eine schnelle und unbürokratische
Aufnahme ermöglicht liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen hinter jeder
Fluchtgeschichte steckt ein Mensch
mit Hoffnungen
Ängsten und Nöten
achten Sie deshalb auf ihre Wortwahl
verteilen Sie mit uns des humanitäre
Asylrecht auf Asyl und arbeiten wir
gemeinsam an pragmatische pragmatische
Lösungen herzlichen Dank
[Applaus]
zum Antrag der Unionsfraktion um den es
hier geht um die Migrationspolitik
Deutschlands da gibt es unterschiedliche
Auffassungen zu diesem Antrag aber
Faktenlage ist dass von Jahresbeginn bis
September nach Angaben des Bundes fast
135.000 Menschen ein Erstantrag auf Asyl
gestellt haben und damit knappe 35% mehr
als im Vorjahreszeitraum das Problem
also ist da ob die jeweiligen
angänge zu Lösungen die richtigen sind
darüber streitet der Bundestag und da
spricht jetzt Josef Oster aus der
Unionsfraktion
genau durchzulesen meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
deutschland leistet großartiges rund 1,2
Millionen Menschen haben in den
vergangenen Monaten in den vergangenen
acht Monaten bei uns Schutz und Zuflucht
gefunden das ist eine großartige
Leistung gegenüber der Ukraine aber
gegenüber auch vielen Menschen die aus
anderen Ländern zu uns gekommen sind im
Durchschnitt waren das rund 5000
Menschen die wir jeden Tag in
Deutschland aufgenommen haben eine
Leistung das will ich hier betonen auf
die unser Land stolz sein darf meine
sehr geehrten Damen und
aber eine Leistung die vor allen Dingen
von unseren Städten und Gemeinden und
von zahllosen ehrenamtlichen geschultert
wird und wohlgemerkt nicht von unserer
Bundesregierung ihr Beitrag ist dabei
höchst überschaubar kaum Steuerung kaum
finanzielle Hilfe die Bundesregierung
scheint die Realität nicht wahrnehmen zu
wollen weder in Bezug auf die Situation
in unserem Land noch in Bezug auf die
Situation in Europa meine lieben
Kolleginnen und Kollegen unsere Kommunen
sind an der Belastungsgrenze und ich
nehme die Warnungen insbesondere unserer
kommunalen Spitzenverbände ausgesprochen
Ernst das Ergebnis des Gipfels
vorgestern bei der Innenministerin ist
vor diesem Hintergrund
ausgesprochen mager das Ergebnis das
rund 4.000 zusätzliche
Unterbringungsmöglichkeiten angeboten
werden sollen entspricht ungefähr dem
Tagesbedarf im Durchschnitt der letzten
Monate wäre ich heute noch Bürgermeister
ich käme mir ver davor meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren
und wenn ich hier aus den
Regierungsfraktionen so manche
Äußerungen höre dann frage ich mich wann
waren die Kolleginnen und Kollegen aus
den Regierungsfraktionen zuletzt in
ihren Wahlkreisen unterwegs und haben
mal mit einem Bürgermeister oder mit
einem Landrat gesprochen oder fahren
oder fahren oder fahren Sie da gar nicht
mehr hin weil sie Angst haben ihr
ideologisches Weltbild könnte ins Wanken
geraten blenden sie ihre Ideologie aus
und öffnen Sie die Augen für die
Realität liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
denn auch die Stimmung in der
Bevölkerung ist heute eine andere eine
kritischere wenn es allen gut geht so
wie das in vergangenen Jahren der Fall
war dann schauen die Menschen über
vieles hinweg in schlechten Zeiten wie
zurzeit gilt das eben nicht und die
Menschen fragen sich schon was macht der
Staat eigentlich mit meinen
Steuergeldern und deshalb müssen wir
darauf achten dass die hohe Gesellschaft
Akzeptanz Menschen die wirklich in Not
sind zu helfen nicht in Gefahr gerät und
deshalb müssen wir darauf achten uns
darauf konzentrieren die illegale
Migration viel konsequenter zu bekämpfen
als das bislang der Fall gewesen ist und
das hat ja sogar die Innenministerin
mittlerweile erkannt und wird dafür von
den Jusos heftig kritisiert einen
schöneren Beleg dafür dass Sie dass Sie
auf dem richtigen Weg ist kann es also
gar nicht geben wenn die Jusos das
kritisieren mal lieben Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
also liebe Bundesregierung
Frau Ministerinnen Liebe Bundesregierung
beenden Sie den deutschen Sonderweg und
verwenden sie alle Kraft darauf einen
gemeinsamen europäischen Weg in der
Migrationspolitik zu finden vielen Dank
Josef Oster aus der Unionsfraktion und
sie ihm wird jetzt folgen katrin
Göring-Eckardt hier im normalen
parlamentsleben Bundestags
Vizepräsidentin aber sie ist auch
Mitglied im Ausschuss für Inneres und
Heimat und als solches spricht sie jetzt
Angela Merkel hat den nansenpreis
bekommen in der letzten Woche und was
hat sie damit gemacht sie hatten ihn
gewidmet den deutschen
flüchtlingshelferinnen sie liebe
Kolleginnen von der Union beschreiten
jetzt den entgegengesetzten Weg sie
fallen all denjenigen in den Rücken die
helfen die organisieren die Arbeiten in
Verwaltungen ehrenamtlich wo auch immer
das was sie mit ihrem Antrag hier gerade
machen ist Panik zu schüren und sie
machen das auf dem Rücken der
Helferinnen und sie machen es auf dem
Rücken der geflüchteten ich finde es
absurd und der demokratischen und
Diskussion hier nicht würdig meine Damen
und
und nachdem jetzt entlarvt wurde dass
ihr Vorsitzender Friedrich Merz seine
und sein unsäglichen Vorwurf gegen die
geflüchteten aufgrund einer anonymen
telegram-nachricht gemacht hat und Herr
Merz ich will das ich will das ganz ich
will das mal ganz positiv sagen ich will
das mal ganz positiv sagen ich glaube
nämlich nicht ich glaube nicht dass sie
wollten dass sie positiv damit in den
russischen propagandia Medien erschienen
sind aber ich finde es sollte für Sie
für alle die so agieren eine Warnung
sein wenn man auf dem Rücken der
ukrainischen geflüchteten solche Nummern
abzieht dann ist das die Sache
putinsider getrieben wird und vielleicht
machen sie es ohne Absicht aber bitte
überlegen Sie beim nächsten mal ganz
genau was sie sagen damit das nicht
geschieht meine Damen und Herren
und jetzt sind wir im Antrag
schimpfen die nun auch Sonderprogramme
was genau meinen Sie meinen sie die
afghanischen ortskräfte deren Ausreise
schwierig genug ist und bei denen wir im
Wort sind meinen sie die getrennten
Familien der Nachzug sie nicht wollen
und die in der Integration bei uns umso
schwerer fällt je länger sie getrennt
sind meinen sie Kinder die da bleiben
müssen damit ein Elternteil zu anderen
Kindern kommt sorry ich verstehe es
nicht wen meinen sie mit
Sonderprogrammen meinen sie etwa
diejenigen die besonders in Not sind
es drängt mich eigentlich emotional zu
werden an dieser Stelle ich probiere es
trotzdem anders ja die Kommunen erleben
eine große Herausforderung eine Million
Menschen aus der Ukraine sind gekommen
nicht alle geblieben vernünftigerweise
stellen sich die Kommunen jetzt auf auf
einen unter anderem Kriegswinter ein in
der Ukraine jetzt kann man Grenzen dicht
machen oder kann Serben sagen Serbien
soll das regeln das haben sie in ihrem
Antrag ja so deutlich gemacht man kann
Panik schön oder man kann sich die Sache
einmal nüchtern betrachten
Humanität und Ordnung heißt es und nicht
Humanität und Abschottung meine Damen
und Herren und die 135 Menschen die
einen Asylantrag gestellt haben es ist
hier schon gesagt worden die sind vor
allem aus Syrien Afghanistan und Iran
was wollen Sie diesen Menschen
eigentlich sagen mit ihrem Antrag
natürlich würde jeder von uns sagen
schnelle Verfahren und damit schnelle
Rückführung damit Menschen wissen woran
Sie sind das ist überhaupt nicht das
Thema und ja die Unterbringung von so
vielen Menschen ist ein enormer Kraft
für unsere Kommunen und die Strukturen
vor Ort und es ist ein guter Schritt das
Bund Länder Kommunen sich zusammensetzen
und dass alle gemeinsam gesagt haben ja
auf der MPK brauchen wir dann eine
Klarheit darüber wie die Finanzierung
funktioniert da sind wir eigentlich aber
meine Damen und Herren Push und pull das
sind eingebildete Faktoren und das ist
wie mit eingebildeter Krankheit
ich meine sie können es ja mal machen
sie können alle Wissenschaftlerinnen und
Wissenschaftler dazu anschauen dann
sehen Sie das ist Quatsch ist und lassen
Sie uns doch andersrum agieren Herr
Oster hat es übrigens gerade gesagt
lassen uns mal andersrum machen wir
könnten uns doch auf unsere Stärken
versuchen zu besinnen und sie könnten
sich auf unsere Stärken besinnen dafür
sorgen dass Integration gelingt dass wir
Chancen für mehr Arbeitskräfte haben und
es geht längst nicht mehr nur um
Fachkräfte fragen Sie mal die
Bauwirtschaft oder das Handwerk meine
Damen und Herren wir könnten gerne
streiten darüber wie das am besten
gelingt aber ich bitte Sie inständig
nicht auf dem Rücken der geflüchteten
Menschen der aus dem Krieg flieht der
braucht unsere Hilfe und nichts anderes
und ich weiß dass manche von ihnen den
merkelsatz wir schaffen das nicht mögen
ich würde ganz einfach mal sagen das ist
die ganz normale Politik dass man Dinge
schafft die beruhen auf Humanität auf
Ordnung auf gutem Willen guter
Zusammenarbeit und unserem Grundgesetz
herzlichen Dank
katrin Göring-Eckardt Mitglied im
Ausschuss für Inneres und Heimat hat
noch mal darauf verwiesen wie groß die
Aufgaben der Kommunen sind nicht zuletzt
wegen der Flüchtlinge aus der Ukraine
und uns ist aufgefallen wie leer
überraschend leer die rein der
afd-fraktion sind und das bei einem
Thema wie der Migrationspolitik hat man
in der Vergangenheit doch eine größere
Präsenz wahrnehmen können bei der AFD am
Pult ist Detlef Seif für die
Unionsfraktion auch erst Mitglied im
Ausschuss für Inneres und Heimat
etwa
927.000 Menschen haben bisher bei uns
vorübergehenden Schutz erhalten und ich
meine das können wir an der Stelle auch
mal deutlich sagen wir können als
Deutschland wirklich stolz darauf sein
dass wir so beherzt vorgegangen sind und
vorgehen und dass wir diese Menschen
vorbehaltlos aufgenommen haben
und auf der anderen Seite
ist natürlich wichtig dass die Hilfe im
Asylrecht den Menschen zu Teil wird
diese auch benötigen ich glaube diesen
Obersatz können wir alle noch
unterstreichen und wir können als wenn
wir die aktuellen Migrationsbewegungen
sehen auch nicht länger leisten dass die
Hilfe denjenigen zu Teil kommt die
keinen Anspruch haben und deshalb ist es
so im Gegensatz zu Deutschland ist bei
dem ganz überwiegenden Teil der
EU-Mitgliedsstaaten mittlerweile eine
sehr restriktive
Asylpolitik auf den Weg gebracht
beispielsweise skandinavische Länder
Frankreich Mittelmeerländer und
Österreich und die Bereitschaft für eine
freiwillige Aufnahme tendiert gegen 0
der Tenor in Europa bloß keine weiteren
Anreize schaffen und die ampelregierung
will das nicht wahrhaben sie beschreitet
in der Tat ein Sonderweg in Europa das
ist hier sind die einzigen die das so
macht sie schafft weitere
aufenthaltsrechtliche und
sozialrechtliche Anreize und Herr Thomé
da muss sich zu ihnen mal deutlich sagen
sie glauben doch nicht wenn Sie ein paar
tausend Menschen die legale Einreise
ermöglichen dass dann der Druck der
Migrationsdruck der in der Welt ist über
100 Millionen Menschen dass der
beseitigt ist und die anderen
99,5 Millionen Menschen sagen wir
wandern jetzt nicht mehr das ist doch
unlogisch das müssen sie auch selbst
einsehen
[Applaus]
und schon im Januar ist die
Innenministerin Tesa ja einseitig mit
einer Koalition der Aufnahme bereiten
Mitgliedsstaaten nach vorne gegangen die
Reaktion war gegen 0 die große Mehrheit
der Länder hat das abgelehnt und dieser
Sonderweg ich weiß dass durch viele
Gespräche der schadet uns in Europa und
international und anstatt durch
innenpolitische
asylexperimente neue Anreize zu schaffen
muss die Ampel endlich die europäischen
und internationalen Baustellen angehen
wir brauchen dringend das grenzverfahren
sprechen sie mit ihren Sozialdemokraten
im Grünen in Brüssel die sind gerade
dabei das nur noch freiwillig
auszugestalten wir brauchen dringend
eine Wiederbelebung des
eu-türkei-abkommens 100.000 Menschen
haben sich aktuell organisiert und
warten auf die Möglichkeit zu uns zu
kommen hier ist die Bundesregierung
gefragt nicht im innenpolitischen klein
sondern international und Serbien
muss zur Zeit dreh- und Angelpunkt ist
ein Hotspot im ganzen 28 Länder können
also die Drittstaatsangehörigen von 28
Ländern visafrei einreisen Serbien guckt
Weg als Transitland und das macht im
Moment auch den großen Druck auf der
Balkanroute aus und ich habe es gestern
schon mal in der Debatte gesagt aber das
Thema ist ganz wichtig es gibt
anerkannte Asylbewerber in Italien
Griechenland und anderen Ländern die
kommen zu uns reisen legal einstellen
hier in Asylantrag und unsere Gerichte
sagen ihr könnt die nicht mehr
zurückschicken in die Länder wo sie
anerkannt sind sondern ihr müsst hier
neues Verfahren durchführen was ist das
denn für ein europäisches System hier
erwarte ich den Druck der
Bundesregierung diplomatisch und
international tätig zu werden
und mit ihrem europäischen Sonderweg ist
die Ampel zurzeit Teil des Problems und
eben nicht der Lösung komme ich nehmen
Sie Abstand von ihren asylexperimenten
und setzen sie europäisch und
international endlich die dringend
erforderlichen Impulse und zeigen sie
endlich Führung das erwarten die
Mitgliedsländer von uns vielen Dank
für die Unionsfraktion ihm wird jetzt
Folgen aus der FDP-Fraktion
an weruschka Jurisch auch sie ist wie
die meisten Rednerinnen und Redner in
dieser Debatte Mitglied im Ausschuss für
Inneres und Heimat meine lieben
Kolleginnen und Kollegen als ich ihren
Antrag gelesen habe habe ich gedacht wie
gut dass wir durch die Ampelkoalition
endlich in der Migrationspolitik
Fortschritt gestalten können ja über die
klassischen fluchtroten kommen in diesem
Jahr deutlich mehr Menschen als in den
beiden corona-jahren davor dieses Jahr
haben bei uns wie sie auch gesagt haben
bisher 156.000 Menschen ein Asylantrag
gestellt das sind 20 Prozent mehr als im
letzten vor corona-jahr 2019 im gleichen
Zeitraum aber das sind bei weitem nicht
die Zahlen wie 2015 20 16 also keine
falschen narrative für die Kommunen ist
es doch im Moment das Hauptproblem über
eine Million geflüchtete Menschen aus
der Ukraine unterzubringen das ist eine
riesige Herausforderung für unsere
Kommunen das Hauptproblem das wir Moment
haben ist Putins Krieg und nicht die
Flüchtlinge auf der Balkanroute
angstpolitik ist gerade jetzt wirklich
komplett verfehlt
für unsere Kommunen wünsche ich mir von
Ministerin Fräser neben den vielen guten
Maßnahmen die Sie eingeleitet hat sehr
klare Worte in Richtung ihrer
europäischen Kollegen im rate
Innenminister der heute und morgen
stattfindet denn ganz besonders muss im
Rat der bisher wirklich nicht
funktionierende freiwillige
solidaritätsmechanismus zur Umverteilung
von Flüchtlingen aus der Ukraine ein
großes Thema werden da geht wirklich
mehr hier brauchen wir kreative Lösungen
wieso kann zum Beispiel nicht Frankreich
ganz pragmatisch aus grenznahen Regionen
in Deutschland ukrainische geflüchtete
aufnehmen so was muss thematisiert
werden ich möchte aber trotzdem hier
weil ihr Antrag das ja auch
herausfordert über die Menschen sprechen
die auch in diesem Jahr irregulär bei
uns eingereist sind genauso übrigens
auch wie in den Jahren unter Herrn
Seehofer es sind nach wie vor zu viele
Menschen die auf gefährlichen wegen zu
uns gelangen viele davon sind Menschen
die in ihrer Heimat keine Perspektive
für sich sehen
wir Freie Demokraten schlagen zusammen
mit unseren Koalitionspartnern einen
neuen Weg vor neben Schutz
Verfahrensbeschleunigung und
rückführungsoffensive gibt es ein
weiteres wirksames Mittel gegen
irreguläre Migrationen über das bisher
viel zu wenig gesprochen wurde wir
brauchen mehr legale migrationswege zu
uns und zwar in unseren Arbeitsmarkt
dass das funktioniert zeigt uns die
westbalkanregel die sie in der großen
Koalition ja auch eingeführt haben
Menschen aus den westbalkanstaaten die
ein Arbeitsplatz bei uns vorweisen
können können zu uns kommen und das
Ergebnis der irregulären migrationdruck
aus diesen Ländern hat bei uns massiv
abgenommen die Mehrheit dieser Menschen
arbeitet bei uns als Fachkräfte die
Wirtschaft bitte dringend darum die
westbalkanregel zu entfristen und die
Kontingentierung aufzuheben an diesem
Erfolgsmodell wollen wir anknüpfen und
es ausweiten
es bringt den einwandernden Menschen
nutzen die nicht Fluchtwege einschlagen
müssen obwohl Sie einfach bei uns
arbeiten wollen und es bringt auch
unserem Land nutzen denn wir brauchen
diese Menschen in Deutschland gibt es
einen riesigen Bedarf an Arbeits- und
Fachkräften Boston Consulting
prognostiziert in einer aktuellen Studie
ein jährlichen Verlust an
Wirtschaftsleistungen in Höhe von 86
Milliarden Euro pro Jahr in Deutschland
wegen Arbeits- und Fachkräftemangels
wenn wir das gut lösen haben wir ein
riesiges Potenzial
als Ampel wollen wir den
Arbeitskräftemangel auch durch
Arbeitskräfte arbeitseinwanderung Decken
der gut sichtbare Leuchtturm wird dabei
ein Punktesystem sein nach kanadischen
Vorbild Arbeitschancen für die die bei
uns sich engagieren wollen daran
arbeiten wir an der Ampel für die
Zukunftsfähigkeit unseres Landes mehr
reguläre Migration weniger angstland
mehr chancenland ich danke Ihnen für
Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
Jurisch aus der FDP-Fraktion ihr wird
jetzt folgen hell gelind aus der
SPD-Fraktion auch er Mitglied im
Ausschuss für Inneres und Heimat der ist
aber auch Vorsitzender des
integrationsrats in Wuppertal
ich bitte und das mache ich jetzt nicht
im Gestus des Tribunals die CDU-Fraktion
ganz ausdrücklich
wieder zu einem kursstaatspolitischer
Verantwortung zurückzukehren und das
ganz deutlich wie sie ist in der Merkel
ihrer bewiesen haben denn es war diesem
Land in der Vergangenheit wenn sie in
die Geschichtsbücher kaufen dem Land und
übrigens auch der CDU immer dann gedient
wenn sie sich dieser staatspolitischen
Verantwortung erinnerten und es half
diesem Land und der CDU übrigens auch
wenn Sie sich an den Unterschied
zwischen Konservatismus und Populismus
erinnerten die scheinen das vergessen zu
haben das ist eine schmale aber
entscheidende Grenze und diese Grenze
sollte man auch kontrollieren und sie
haben das momentan vernachlässigt und
schon andere haben das vorher in ihren
eigenen Reihen erkannt es ist nämlich
nicht das erste Mal sondern es hat eine
Vorgeschichte
2000 Rita sie ist mit erinnerte
Friedrich Merz also die Akteure haben
sich nicht fundamental geändert daran
bitte nicht die Emotionalisierung gegen
Ausländer zum Wahlkampfthema zu machen
ich schließe mich ausdrücklich Rita
Süßmuth an und wenn wir uns die
Wahlergebnisse angucken scheint es ja
auch kein Erfolgsmodell zu sein so zu
agieren
verräterisch ist insbesondere deshalb
auch der Hinweis auf staatspolitische
Verantwortung die Sprache sie reden von
einem Sonderweg den Begriff Sonderweg
hat Hans-Ulrich Wehler geprägt als den
deutschen Sonderweg der mündete in den
Nationalsozialismus ich appelliere an
Sie
reflektierter und sensibler mit ihrem
Sprachgebrauch umzugehen und sie haben
gestern Herr Seif in der redewort
wörtlich gesagt dass bei 40 Prozent
Anerkennung dass im Umkehrschluss
bedeuten würde dass 60 Prozent Zitat das
System ausnutzen diese Schlussfolgerung
ist schlicht unwahr und unredlich und
einfach auch noch unanständig denn zu
diesen von ihnen behaupten 60% gehören
queere verfolgte die keine Planung
gefunden haben dazu gehören Personen die
Perspektiven gesucht haben aber
mitnichten können sie behaupten dass all
diejenigen die eine Ablehnung in
Asylverfahren erhalten Schmarotzer sein
und das war ihre unredliche Behauptung
und sie ist verachtenswert und da komme
ich noch zu einem dritten Punkt
sie sprechen davon dass die Ampel Tür
und Tor öffnen würde stattdessen macht
aber die Innenministerin zusammen mit
der Koalition Politik statt Angst zu
beschwören ohne konstruktive
Lösungsansätze was sie tun denn sie geht
alles zusammen an die Situation mit der
Ukraine die wir gar nicht steuern können
denn das liegt in der Hand des
verbrecherischen putin-regimes aber auch
der Entscheidung von Ukraine und grünern
ein Afghanistan Aufnahmeprogramm zuletzt
ganz bewusst adressiert die
Innenministerin die Frage der
Balkanroute und sie sieht aber zugleich
auch dass wir einfach nicht hingucken
können wenn Menschen buchstäblich
verrecken im Sachen sehen und Rettung
und das ist nicht klug ist mit der
libyschen Küstenwache zusammenzuarbeiten
das ist ein komplexer Politikansatz das
nenne ich Politik statt Beschwörung von
Angst und das ist unsere verdammte
Aufgabe es war früher mal früher mal
eine Selbstverständlichkeit in Länder
und Bundes-
bei allen Differenzen auch die
Opposition den Kurs der Regierung
getragen hat weil man wusste dass das
kein Thema ist dass sich dazu eignet
Stimmung zu machen diesen Konsens haben
sie leider verlassen und das ist
bedauernswert und ein letztes
es ist auch sicherheitspolitisch und
volkswirtschaftlich dumm wenn wir
Menschen über Chancen Aufenthalt und
Bleiberecht die Möglichkeit geben hier
als schon gut integrierte tatsächlich
darauf zu leben bekommen Sie keine
Transferleistung sondern können
dauerhaft Arbeiten Steuern zahlen
Sozialversicherungsbeiträge leisten das
heißt es ist budgetär sogar ein Gewinn
die Personen sind stabilisiert ein
entscheidender Faktor und das ist
Duldung für Kriminalität und
Radikalisierung fällt weg also auch
einem sicherheitspolitische Maßnahme und
ein drittes sie mögen doch sowieso das
Thema Anreize wir hatten bisher den
Anreiz seine Identität nicht zu klären
weil dann die Abschiebung drohte wenn
wir jetzt ganz pragmatisch ein Anreizen
setzen dass Identität klärt dann haben
wir mehr Kenntnis über die Entität mehr
Ordnung und mehr Sicherheit dafür steht
diese Regierung mehr Ordnung mehr
Sicherheit Anstand Menschlichkeit
orientieren sie sich daran und werden
sie endlich ihrer Verantwortung gerecht
vielen Dank
Helge Lindt aus der SPD-Fraktion und
sein Beitrag begann zumindest mit einem
Blick auf die Metaebene und zwar auf die
der Sprache in der
Migrationsdebatte nächster Redner ist
Philipp Amthor aus der cdu/csu-fraktion
besondere lieber Herr Kollege Lindt
Inhalt mal zwei klare Feststellung zu
machen Feststellungen Nummer eins
staatspolitische Verantwortung ist nicht
nur die Parteiprogramm matik der Linken
Ampelkoalition meine Damen und Herren
und Feststellung Nummer 2 zu
staatspolitischer Verantwortung gehört
ist sich den Realitäten in unserem Land
zu stellen und nicht diese
Realitätsverweigerung zu betreiben die
wir hier in der Debatte gehört haben man
fragt sich doch wirklich wann manche von
ihnen das letzte Mal mit Land treten und
Bürgermeister angesprochen haben unsere
Kommunen Steuern zu auf die Grenzen
ihrer Belastungsfähigkeit in der
gesellschaftlich angespannten Situation
gibt es Überlegungen Turnhallen wieder
zu schließen für den Vereinssport und
das Reden sie ja alles schön das hat mit
Lebensrealität nichts zu tun liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sie geben sich
linken Tagträume rein hin und vor allem
was ich bemerkenswert finde an dieser
Debatte sie hat reisten sich hier zum
Teil uns als
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion
sprechverbote und Haltungsnoten zu geben
das steht müssen in keiner Weise zu
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir
lassen uns keine sprechverbote erteilen
und ich sage Ihnen auch eines unser
Antrag hat nichts mit AFD sprechen wie
sie das nennen zu tun und sie machen es
sich intellektuell auch ziemlich leicht
wenn sie sonst keine inhaltlichen
Argumente liefern können unsere
Migrationspolitik positioniert sich
stattdessen ganz klar zwischen ihren
beiden ideologischen Polen wir haben
nichts gemein mit ihrer
Migrationspolitik die am Ende darauf
hinausläuft dass sie das Ende des
Asylrechts wollen wir wollen nicht das
Ende des Asylrechts wir wollen ein Ende
des Missbrauchs des Asylrechts liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen das ist der
Unterschied und wir sehen Zuwanderung
nicht nur mit Angst sondern auch mit
Chancen das sehen Sie nicht und das
unterscheidet uns von der AFD und von
ihnen unterscheidet uns ganz klar dass
wir uns diesen Lebensrealitäten stellen
es ist doch
in aller Realität dass sie hier so tun
dass man in eine rechtsextreme Ecke am
besten gestellt wird wenn wir darauf
hinweisen dass wir erhebliche Belastung
auch für unsere sozialen
Versicherungssysteme haben wenn wir die
Zuwanderung ungezügeln zulassen das muss
man in diesem Parlament sagen und das
ist die Lebensrealität über den
Küchentischen in den allermeisten
Städten und Gemeinden in unseren Land in
unserem Land den Sie sich stellen
sollten und ich will Ihnen auch ganz
klar sagen Entschuldigung Herr Kollege
Abenteuer erlauben sie eine
Zwischenfrage aus der Fraktion der
Grünen ja gerne das gibt mir die
Gelegenheit noch auf manches einzugehen
danke dass du die frischen Zwischenfrage
zulässt du bist ja hier eine der ganz
großen Juristen im Raum und ich finde
das dann immer spannend wenn man von dem
Juristen hört dass es ja die
gesellschaftliche Akzeptanz vielleicht
nicht mehr so gibt und man deshalb ja
nicht mehr so viele Menschen aufnehmen
will das ist glaube ich einer der ganz
ganz großen Trugschlüsse den du und den
dem ihr hier gerade alle aufgesessen
seid nämlich dass deine Fraktion glaubt
dass nur weil die weil die CDU
Wählerschaft vielleicht in Teilen ein
Problem damit hat dass deshalb das
Asylrecht nicht mehr gilt dass deshalb
an den Grenzen Menschen abgewiesen
werden müssen das muss uns wirklich zu
denken geben und dass man euch deshalb
in die rechte Ecke stellt das ist
tatsächlich richtig denn da kommt genau
dieses Gedankengut her das zweite es ist
schon viel davon gesprochen worden vom
sogenannten sogfaktor vom bulleffekt ihr
habt mit Sicherheit auch gestern mal in
die Tagesschau App geguckt abgesehen da
gibt es so einen kleinen Faktencheck und
auch mal das was der Friedrich Merz
gesagt hat so ein bisschen auseinander
genommen immer geguckt und das die
Bewertung des sogenannten pullfaktors
wird dort eigentlich nur als eine
waage-idee bezeichnet so ein bisschen
als anekdotische Evidenz und meine Frage
meine Frage an dich Philipp wäre was
habt ihr eigentlich für einen Beleg für
den Pull Faktor könnt ihr mir eine
Studie nennen wirklich jetzt musste ganz
kurze Antwort ich möchte noch mal hören
gibt es eine einzige Studie nach dem
Jahr 1990 die den bullfaktor belegt und
wenn ja wie lautet die damit wir uns
dieser Debatte nicht wirklich
weitergeholfen
frau Präsidentin vielen Dank also eine
in vielerlei Hinsicht bemerkenswerte
Wortmeldung liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ich danke zunächst für das
duzangebot aber ich bin auch froh dass
wir hier nicht im Studentenparlament
sondern im Deutschen Bundestag sind das
zum einen und ich finde das sollte auch
im Niveau zur Geltung kommen ich danke
auch auf den Hinweis darauf dass ich das
aus juristischer Perspektive bewertet
habe tut vielleicht auch dem einen oder
anderen nicht schlecht wenn es hier im
deutschen Parlament auch noch Leute mit
einem Studienabschluss gibt will ich
auch sagen vielleicht auch nicht
verkehrt und im übrigen auch inhaltlich
der Hinweis der Hinweis ist natürlich
völlig irgendwie getrieben von einer
Fakten entleerten Politik natürlich gibt
es diese anreizfaktoren einen pulfaktor
was glauben Sie denn warum die Menschen
in Europa die Durchreise von Bulgarien
von sonstwo nach Deutschland machen weil
die Grünen hier so tolle Politik machen
oder was nein natürlich hat das auch zu
tun mit unseren sozialen
Sicherungssystemen und mit dem Umfeld
unseres wunderbaren Landes das
Deutschland liefert und zu den Fakten
können wir uns gerne austauschen
herzliche Einladung dazu zu einer
vertieften Diskussion am Ende hilft es
hier dass wir uns auch noch in den
Lebensrealitäten der Menschen bewegen
und davon haben sie sich sehr sehr weit
verabschiedet und deswegen ich will es
zum Abschluss sagen diese Debatte die
wir hier heute erleben begonnen mit dem
Bürgergeld Abkehr von fördern und
fordern jetzt das völlige leugnen von
Risiken der Migration für die sozialen
Versicherungssysteme da muss man doch
sagen am Ende können sich die Menschen
die die Sozialleistungen erarbeiten die
Sie hier alle verteilen wollen nach
dieser Debatte doch wirklich nur
kopfschüttelnd an den Kopf fassen und
das werden wir adressieren und dafür
lassen wir uns von ihnen keine
sprechverbote erteilen herzlichen Dank
liebe Kolleginnen und
Philipp Amthor aus der
Unionsfraktion ihm wird jetzt Folgen aus
der SPD-Fraktion Lars castellucci Essen
migrations- und integrationspolitischer
Sprecher und außerdem stellvertretender
Vorsitzender des Innenausschusses hier
im Bundestag
vielen Dank sehr geehrte Frau
Präsidentin meine sehr verehrten Damen
und Herren liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
zum Thema Realität also unsere
Wirklichkeit
ist im Moment in allererster Linie sehr
geehrter Herr Amthor wenn Sie mir Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit widmen würden dadurch
ausgezeichnet das eine Million Menschen
aus der Ukraine nach Deutschland
gekommen sind weil sie von Putin in
einen in einem Angriffskrieg gezwungen
worden sind ihre Heimat zu verlassen und
ja da werden jetzt auch wieder
Turnhallen benötigt dafür aber ich finde
das ist eine Gemeinschaftsleistung in
diesem Land dass wir diesen Menschen in
dieser existenziellen Lage an der Seite
stehen auf die wir stolz sein können da
danke ich allen die mit anpacken zweiter
Teil der Realität das was wir jetzt hier
vorfinden in Deutschland ist Ergebnis
von 16 Jahren
Innenminister der Union und wir machen
in dieser Koalition einen Neuanfang in
der Migrationspolitik weil ihre Politik
gescheitert ist sie ist sie ist
gescheitert und man kann es sehen an den
Außengrenzen wo ihre Politik immer nur
dazu geführt hat dass das Leid der
Menschen größer geworden ist und wenn
das Leid der Menschen an den Routen
entlang größ dann machen Sie sich doch
erst recht auf den Weg und suchen noch
mal nach Perspektiven und wir sind
angetreten das umzudrehen dass die
Menschenwürde der Menschen entlang der
Routen durchgesetzt wird das ist die
Aufgabe vor der wir stehen
und das zweite was sie uns beschert
haben
ob sie jetzt gerade ein Haus bauen
wollen oder ob Sie in Urlaub fliegen
wollen oder ob sie nur Blumenstrauß
gebunden haben wollen wir haben in
diesem Land einen eklatanten
Fachkräftemangel und dieser
Fachkräftemangel der liegt daran dass
sie eine
Abwehrhaltung haben gegenüber Migration
und gegenüber Menschen aus anderen
Ländern das ist der Fachkräftemangel der
Union indem wir im Moment gefangen sind
und es ist ein Wachstums eine
Wachstumsgrenze für unser Land und wir
werden das Verändern diese Koalition hat
klare Prinzipien wir wollen Migrationen
so gestalten dass sie zum Wohle aller
Beteiligten gelingen kann der Menschen
die migrieren die wandern der Menschen
die zurückbleiben die dann
Rücküberweisungen bekommen aber
natürlich auch uns weil wir eben auch
einen Bedarf haben an Arbeitskräften die
hier in diesem Land mit anpacken
und wir haben einen zweiten Grundsatz
wenn Menschen vor Krieg fliehen wenn sie
in Not sind wenn sie Hilfe brauchen dann
haben Sie unsere Menschlichkeit und
Solidarität verdient im übrigen wie
jeder Mensch in diesem Land wir haben
bevor wir in diese Debatte eingestiegen
sind über das Bürgergeld gesprochen wir
werden wenn diese Debatte beendet ist
über die wohngeldreform sprechen diese
Regierung lässt niemanden allein es gibt
keine Menschen erster und zweiter Klasse
wir stehen an der Seite aller Menschen
die Hilfe brauchen und ich will Ihnen
auch noch mal eins sagen wenn sie immer
sagen wir können nicht allen Menschen
helfen das ist eine Binsenweisheit aber
es ist keine Entschuldigung den Menschen
zu helfen den man helfen kann und das
ist der Auftrag den sich diese Koalition
gestellt hat regelbasiert konsequent
aber auch menschlich diesen Weg gehen
wir und dafür kann ich der
Bundesregierung die volle Unterstützung
der SPD-Bundestagsfraktion zu sagen
war das noch mal für die SPD-Fraktion
Matthias Helfrich wird der nächste
Redner sein fraktionslos früher mal AFD
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren es war ja
bisher bekannt dass die Amnesie im
Bundeskanzleramt kassiert neu ist aber
dass die Amnesie pandemisch geworden ist
und nunmehr auch die scheinen
Oppositionelle cdu/csu-fraktion
ergriffen hat es waren doch sie liebe
Christdemokraten die sich 2015 mit einem
willkommens-putsch an unserer Heimat
versündigt haben es waren doch sie die
Deutschland in einem Akt des
souveränitätsverzichts der
Massenzuwanderung ausgeliefert haben da
können mich gerne nachäffen und das
belächeln es war nämlich auch sie die
die ich will gucken nach Fries nach
Deutschland eingeladen haben die dann
nachher auf der Kölner Domplatte unsere
Frauen belästigten beklauten und
begraften schon vergessen das waren sie
von der CDU aber unter guten
Christenmenschen ist es ja üblich zu
vergeben und an die Leute rund des
Sünders zu glauben Manfred Weber ging
hier ja bereits als Gläubiger und
geläuterter Paulus voran und gratulierte
weil Siegerin Georgia Meloni in Teilen
ist ihre Analyse richtig aber sie leidet
unter einem falschen Werte Horizont die
Zielgrößen ihres Maßnahmenkataloges sind
die falschen es geht bei der Bekämpfung
der illegalen Migration nicht um die
Akzeptanz eines dysfunktionalen
Asylsystems und einer gescheiterten
Einwanderungsgesellschaft nein es muss
bei der Bekämpfung der
illegalen Migration um den Erhalt
Deutschlands als Land der deutschen
gehen und eine Forderung gefällt mir
ganz besonders gut von ihm unter Ziffer
7 fordern sie ja die Einführung eines
sogenannten
rückführungsbeauftragten und wenn sich
die Ampel einig ist die er eine
rückführungsoffensive wünscht und sie
ein rückführungsbeauftragten Wünschen
der dann würde ich mich als
überparteilicher
chemikationsbeauftragte anbieten und ich
verspreche Ihnen abzuschieben wie noch
nie in diesem Land abgeschoben werden
wurde und sollten wir uns nicht auf mich
einigen können dann geht weiterhin Jörg
Haiders Alter Grundsatz bevor die polit
das Volk austauschen sollte das Volk die
Politiker austauschen und das gilt für
die Unionspolitiker genauso wie für die
ampelpolitiker vielen Dank
Mathias Helferich fraktionslos und ich
habe vorhin gesagt früher AFD Mitglied
in der AFD ist ja immer noch aber er
gehört der Fraktion nicht mehr an
vor so und dann wird er möglicherweise
noch einen Ordnungsruf bekommen von
einer ösus der Bundestagsvizepräsidentin
für einen Ausdruck den er in seiner Rede
verwendet hat nächster Redner Marcel
Emmerich Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
ob man im Innenausschuss
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine
Damen und Herren
wenn man sich diese Debatte jetzt mal
wieder angehört hat wir sind ja schon am
Ende der Debatte fast dann muss man sich
einfach ja kann man einfach feststellen
auch wenn man sich ihren Antrag noch mal
durchliest dass das was die Union hier
verbreitet und ihrem Antrag
aufgeschrieben hat er ein
migrationspolitischer Irrweg ist und
nicht unsere Politik ein
migrationspolitischer politischer
Sonderweg das kann man mal zweifellos
feststellen an dieser Stelle und sie
haben uns den Vertreterinnen und
Vertreter der koalitionsfraktion
vorgeworfen dass wir keinen Kontakt
hätten zu den Kommunen zu den
Landrätinnen und Landräten ich glaube
das mitnichten der Fall das haben wir
alle und die bundesinnenministerin hat
mit den über 50
bundesimmobilien die sie da zur
Entlastung
bereitstellt auch gezeigt dass sie den
Druck wahrnimmt und dass da etwas
passiert das heißt wir sind da
handlungsfähig und helfen den Kommunen
und den Ländern
und wenn man sich hier einen Antrag
anschaut dann muss man ja schon mal
feststellen dass das ist keine
Überraschungen aber wo ist denn
eigentlich ihr sozialer Flügel wo ist
denn eigentlich ihr christlich
orientierter Flügel sie sind vollkommen
weg wenn man ihre reden hört dann stellt
man fest dass es ihnen in Wahrheit darum
geht und dass sie richtig juckt mal
wieder das Wort Obergrenzen in den Mund
zu nehmen ihr Parteivorsitzender März
hat ja auch das schon alles mit den
narrativen vorbereitet mit dem
sozialtourismus und der
Entsolidarisierung mit den geflüchteten
aus der Ukraine und jetzt gehen sie her
und bekämpfen die geflüchteten die über
die Balkanroute kommen in dem ersten
Schritt um dann in einem späteren
zweiten Schritt zu sagen wir brauchen
eine Obergrenze das ist die Debatte die
Sie gerade vorbereiten und das ist ein
vollkommener migrationspolitischer
Irrweg den wir nicht mitgehen
und wo ist denn ihr Wirtschaftsflügel
der ist auch überhaupt nicht da wenn man
im Wahlkreis unterwegs ist das könnten
Sie übrigens mal machen bei
Handwerksbetrieben dann stellt man fest
dass es überall fehlt egal ob sie in der
Bäckerei ist oder wenn man unterwegs ist
in dem Altenheim da viel Pflegepersonal
überall fehlt Personal überall fehlen
Leute egal ob es einfache Arbeitskräfte
oder Fachkräfte sind und das was sie
hier vorschlagen ist Abschottung und
Ausgrenzung und hat überhaupt nichts mit
einer vernünftigen mit einer geregelten
asyl- und Migrationspolitik zu tun
sondern ist einfach nur Schranken
hochziehen und keine Menschen mehr
reinlassen sie wollen ein großes
Stoppschild errichten so wie sie das
auch in den letzten Jahren mit den
Grenzkontrollen gemacht haben wie sie
das mit der Forderung nach dem
Grenzkontrollen nach Tschechien jetzt
tun die Grenzkontrollen sie sind Schaden
der Wirtschaft die Grenzkontrollen
belasten die Menschen in der Grenzregion
und sie dienen nicht unserer Sicherheit
stattdessen gibt es viele andere bessere
Alternativen die wir da an den auf den
Weg bringen
und das machen wir auch als Koalition
das ist unser als grüner Fraktion ein
sehr sehr wichtiges Anliegen wir
betreiben ihr Spiel kommen auf keinen
Fall mit wir werden uns dagegen
auflehnen sie können hier fordern und
sprechen wie Sie wollen aber ihre
Politik die wird bei uns kein Einheit
geboten kommen
Marcel Emmerich und das geht mir die
Gelegenheit noch eine kleine Korrektur
anzubringen zu der Anmerkung von
Bundestagsvizepräsidentin Aydan özos
eben überzogen auf die Rede von Matthias
Helferich es ging nicht um einen
Ausdruck sondern es ging darum was er
hochgehalten hat das wollte sie sich
noch mal angucken
sicherheitshalber und dann sich hat sich
dann vorbehalten einen Ordnungsruf unter
Umständen nachträglich zu erteilen wenn
sie es dann gesehen hat Josip youratovic
ist am Pult dass der letzte Redner in
dieser Debatte und er kommt aus der
SPD-Fraktion der Migrationspolitik und
asylrechtsfragen vermischt werden
Migrationspolitik ist mehr
als nur Asylrecht bei Migrationspolitik
geht es in erster Linie um Integration
in unserer Gesellschaft und in den
Arbeitsmarkt deswegen werden wir wie im
Koalitionsvertrag gefordert Deutschland
zu einem modernen Einwanderungsland
machen dies befördert die reguläre
Migration die automatisch die irreguläre
reduziert den Fakt ist angesichts der
fehlenden 400.000 Beschäftigten in
Deutschland brauchen wir die Migration
die es in die europäische Raum nicht
mehr so gibt deshalb begrüße ich
ausdrücklich die Maßnahme der
Bundesregierung wie zum Beispiel das
Chancen Aufenthaltsrecht dies bietet
auch den jungen Menschen die zu uns
Pflichten sich hier zu integrieren und
sich zu unsere freiheitlichen
demokratischen Grundordnung bekennen
sowie sich beruflich einbringen die
Möglichkeit hier bleiben zu können statt
in der Ungewissheit der Duldungen zu
verhandeln
Kolleginnen und Kollegen und gerade Herr
throm sie wissen selbst die Diskussionen
die man täglich fährt in unserem
Wahlkreis nämlich dass die gerade die
Unternehmer und Ausbilder nicht die Welt
verstehen ihren dass sie junge
MigrantInnen und ausbilden und sie dann
abzuschieben
während wir hier tenderinnen
nach dem gesucht suchen mit anderen
Worten der die reguläre Migration
stärken und die irreguläre Migration
reduzieren will dem helfen keine
zusätzliche Schranken vielmehr müssen
wir als DemokratInnen einen rechtlichen
Rahmen auf den Grundlage von mehr
Menschlichkeit statt Rainer Bürokratie
schaffen dies verlangen von uns
Millionen von MitbürgerInnen die mit
ihren unermüdlichen Einsatz helfen das
menschliche Gesicht unserer Gesellschaft
zu wahren statt hier wie von
verschiedenen Kollegen der CDU
halbherzige Lob zu bekunden und wenn es
schon um eine Veränderung oder eine
Veränderung geben soll muss man sich im
europäischen Rahmen Gedanken machen wie
wir die Best West bestehende
Konventionen anpassen indem wir die
Fluchtursachen neu definieren neu
definieren und anerkennen so zum
Beispiel dass man den Krieg auch nach
dem dass man neben dem Krieg auch
Umweltschäden und Hungersnot als
Fluchtursachen Berichte
dabei muss man sich Gedanken machen die
wir angesichts weltweit 90 Millionen
Flüchtlingen fluchtortsachen bekämpfen
statt neue bürokratische Hürde oder gar
Zäune an den Grenzen aufstellen so zum
Beispiel ist meines Erachtens nach
wichtig dass wir in unserer Außen- und
Entwicklungspolitik in den
Herkunftsländer neben den
wirtschaftlichen Zusammenarbeit auch den
Sozialstaat konditionell als wichtigen
Bestandteil der Demokratie exportieren
und zum Schluss kann ich mir nicht
verkneifen als gläubiger Christ in das
sozialdemokratischen Partei gerade sie
von der Union als christliche Partei
sollten eins Wissen der Jesus Christus
war der prominenteste Flüchtling und
alles was sie tun in ihrer Politik
gegenüber den Flüchtlingen tun sie den
denn Jesus Christus an danke für Ihre
aufmerksam
mit einem christlichen Zitat er ist ja
auch Vorsitzender der
deutsch-süd-osteuropäischen
Parlamentariergruppe und in diesem
umkontext war ja auch die Grenzen
Serbiens immer wieder ein Thema in
dieser Debatte der Antrag der
Unionsfraktion wird überwiesen in den
Innenausschuss und da noch mal
diskutiert